Hi, I'm grant back for another video here on visual politic this week.
Can the U S a B Y, and the 5g race in the bottle for 5g?
Is there even an alternative to why? Why will the USA install Japanese five G?
Why is there no 5g made in America?
Yeah.
It's a country divided into two souls. On the one hand,
we have the American dream, the country,
which Thomas Jefferson dreamed of the land of freedom and opportunity.
No matter where you come from your life will always be better in America.
Yeah.
Business terms. This has come to mean that for decades,
Americans have been free to buy a Mercedes Toyota or Nissan just as easily as
they bought a Chevrolet or a Ford. Now, there is another United States.
The United States of buy American.
We've seen the America in movies like grant arena.
Many Americans look at the label of everything. They buy,
hoping to find a meat and America tag before going to pay at the checkout.
And if there's a president who embodies this spirit, as none other than.
Donald Trump.
Trump signs measure aimed at bolstering his by American initiative.
In this case,
we are talking about an initiative to make the administration prioritize us
products over any other.
But if there is one issue where by American is becoming very visible at his end,
the development of mobile networks, particularly with the arrival of five G.
So let's see how reasonable Trump's stance and his buy American position is,
or whether in the end,
the U S president will have to surrender to the necessity of trading with other
countries. Let's take a look.
[Inaudible].
Once we could say that the internet is a world without borders,
no matter where you come from, we can all compete on an equal footing.
That's why I'm Scottish and presenting this. However,
all the internet giants come from the same place. The United.
Companies.
Amazon, Google, and Facebook are the real Kings of the internet.
And it seemed like the United States was going to remain the undisputed
technological leader until the race for five G came along.
In case you don't know 5g as the next generation of mobile internet,
high speed internet,
which made it pretty ironic that you weren't in that quick on the uptake there,
the move to 5g will allow things like self-driving cars, the internet of things,
and many other digital applications,
and which is the leading company and building 5g networks. It's not Google,
it's not Facebook. It's not even Apple.
The leading company in 5g technology is Huawei a Chinese company,
and that doesn't impress Donald Trump and the.
Donald Trump declared national emergency clearing away to ban Huawei from us
5g networks.
To give you all an idea while we, as a 30% worldwide market share. In fact,
the company has deploying its 5g equipment around Europe. As you can imagine,
Trump does not like this one bit.
We will always remember his presidency for two leitmotifs America first,
and for his obsession with.
China, China, China, China, China. I have to have my China, China, China,
because China, China, China, China, China, China, China, China, that's it.
5G is pretty much his worst nightmare.
It's not just a technology where the us is far from the leader. The kicker is,
is that Shayna is winning by a country mile. However,
the United States cannot afford to not have 5g networks.
And right now doing it without Weiwei is almost impossible.
[Inaudible].
While way offers the best technology and is up to 20% cheaper than any other
alternative. So the question is,
is it possible for the United States to turn its back on China without losing
competitiveness,
will the United States be able to generate a competitive alternative to go up
against Huawei? Can America really win the race for 5g today on visual politic?
We will answer those questions, but first let's look at some history.
America first, not always.
You see, believe it or not.
There are economic sectors in which the United States is not at the forefront.
The German group Volkswagen is the world's biggest selling car company from
Mattoon. A company from friends formerly called Arriva leads.
The field of nuclear power globally.
Sweden's Ikea is the leading company and the furniture sector.
And Spain's ACS is the world leader for international turnover in the
construction and engineering businesses. ACS may not sound familiar to you,
but its president is flooding Tino Perez who I'm sure you'll be more familiar
with as the president of Rio,
It goes for a mobile phone networks. Uh, note,
I want to make clear what we're talking about. We,
the consumers contract rates with telephone operators,
there are many operators and quite a few in each country,
but for our devices to work, they have to connect to mobile networks.
That is our devices are connected by radio waves to antennas that cover a
certain area.
These facilities have base stations that have the hardware that supports
communications,
What telecommunications providers, that install 5g networks on a large scale.
Aren't so numerous they're Sweden's Erickson and Finland's Nakia remember them,
but the undisputed leader worldwide is WowWee while we has already seen more
than 50 contracts to develop 5g and more than 30 countries,
the Chinese company has more 5g patents than any other company in the world.
[Inaudible].
Among its main advances.
While we managed to complete the world's first find G call launched the first
integral 5g base station ship and created a terminal capable of supporting
it all. This may sound double Dutch, but as far as technology is concerned,
it is very important. So how did China do it? Well,
we've talked about it recently in this video, you know,
that China's economy is to put it mildly, quite centralized,
whether it's five-year plans and the communist regime has decided that
developing 5g as a top priority.
So they've laid out the red carpet for Huawei to investigate five G.
Everything has been made very easy in China for one of its telecom companies to
become the global reference for the new generation of mobile technologies.
This was recently explained and the wall street journal.
[Inaudible].
Holly freaked out at the wall street journal over a report that it's secured.
It's global tech dominance on the back of 75 billion in state support from
China.
Huawei is currently the second largest mobile phone company and the world after
South Korea, Samsung more than 200 million units are sold each year. However,
selling smartphones is only half of their business.
The other half of its gigantic business is to provide the telecommunications
equipment, the supports mobile networks,
not exactly small change and all of this leads us to notice something else,
Erickson, Nakia, Huawei, Samsung,
but there is no us company that is a world leader in this business. Really.
It seems like in the United States,
there is no company that has been a true telecommunications giant since Francis
Alcatel bought the U S brand loosened. By the way,
Alcatel was later acquired by Nokia. As you can see the same names,
keep coming up over and over again.
So without a us company to fall back on what options does Donald Trump have left
for months? There has been speculation about alternatives. Volcanes.
There are many alternatives available to the Trump administration,
but two methods in particular have gained the most.
Everyone was to encourage one of the us tech giants to buy out one of these
global benchmark telecommunications companies and then jump into the 5g race.
The other,
and even more interventionist option would be to provide financial support to
those bastions of the Western world that Ericsson Nakia have become.
[Inaudible].
But there's no denying.
It is unthinkable that at the end of all this tune and Fruin between the
capitalist and communist model,
the white house will adopt the same tactics as China.
Perhaps it is simply that Western economies are not in a position to replicate
the successful model. Beijing has built with Huawei.
So the Trump administration has focused more on putting spokes and Weiwei's
wheels rather than trying to win the 5g race. We all know how he did it.
He is banned us companies from working with Huawei. For example,
new Huawei smartphones cannot use Google apps as also trying to get other
countries to ban Chinese technology and the deployment of 5g mobile networks
like in my country, Britain. But the truth is the apart from removing Australia,
New Zealand and Japan, few countries are heating Trump's warnings.
Look at what the Qatari of redo. As a note.
[Inaudible].
Do chooses Huawei to build 5g networks in five countries.
My countries are Kuwait, Oman, Indonesia, Tunisia,
and the mole deeps. Do they sound a little exotic to maybe,
but don't think that on the European continent it's any different Huawei knows
how to convince Western governments to it.
France authorizes the use of Huawei equipment in its 5g network while plans for
a new factory are underway.
All indications are that Trump's plan a is not working,
but as there a plan B that is avoiding using the same weapons as China,
this interventionism, that has propelled Huawei.
Is there a possibility of generating a competitive alternative to Chinese
technology? It seems so a note, we're going to take a look at it.
The Rakuten revolution.
In the end,
it seems there's a reason Trump can remain optimistic optimism and Japanese
translates as Rakuten.
I'd like to just take a moment to apologize to all of our Japanese funds there
I'm Scottish. I could barely speak English. As you know,
there's a pretty big company called Rakuten to give you an idea.
It's kind of like the Japanese, Amazon,
but you're probably more familiar with it.
As the main sponsor of Barcelona football club Rakuten was founded in 1997 and
in 2004 was already the most popular company in the country.
It has become Japan's largest e-commerce site. Again,
making machine yen by the mountains, Fuji Yan mountains.
[Inaudible].
Following a success at home Rakuten drag to expand internationally.
And the result is nothing out of the ordinary and Spain made a million dollar
investment, but was unable to compete with Amazon and has already closed.
It looked like they were coming to take over the market.
And in the end they didn't even manage to make some loose change. But viewers,
there is a Japanese proverb that says ship my one sequel, no Moto. Once again,
I really do apologize to Japan,
which means mistakes are the foundations of success.
So recruiting sometimes fails, but they're still trying.
And now they're diversifying.
They have investments in Cabify and global and in Pinterest affiliate is
dedicated to digital banking and payment platforms,
records and travel for holidays, recruiting TV,
which has a Netflix style video on demand platform.
And now I was going to tell you what they're up to, but even better.
Here's Hiroshi, Mikitani Rakuten CEO, and he is going to tell you.
Ha going to deploy, uh, what we call mobile edge computing. And, uh,
in Japan, uh,
we are going to have over 4,000 it's servers all over Japan. Uh,
and therefore, uh, we do not,
we have to create a new network for 5g.
What we need to do is we modify our a server a little bit.
Our core network throughput is VV fast.
So what we have to do is just add 5g antenna,
which we already have developed.
So there you have it. Rakuten has gone into the mobile networking business,
but wait a minute, because we're talking about a new way to build 5g networks.
This is a virtual system.
The functions of mobile networks have been replicated into the cloud.
So with open hardware and 40% cheaper than traditional telecom companies,
Rakuten says it's able to over find G with the quality and speed requirements
necessary.
And some of you will be thinking and the cloud grant leave the red pills alone.
This is not the matrix. Despite the fact that I'm as handsome as Morpheus,
you don't believe me, take a look.
Rakuten and NEC deliver first cloud 5g unit ahead of June launch.
Because these Japanese companies are about to launch are completely
revolutionary, but above all in Trump's size,
it would give him a fantastic advantage. They don't come from China. Otherwise,
if he has to choose between China or Japan, Trump will choose Japan.
And you'll say, but what does this have to do with mate and America? Well,
we're going to see this right now.
[Inaudible].
Made in America. Well kind of.
This point, I think we can sell it.
The race for 5g as a clash between two systems WowWee versus record in and
SFA, very similar to Apple's Basel against windows.
I mean a struggle between what we might call an open system and a closed one,
basically all Huawei 5g technology is owned by Huawei.
There are hardly any other providers.
We are talking about a system based on very good hardware. However,
Rakuten has a completely different philosophy. And this case,
the hardware is not that important. What's more,
they can use simpler and cheaper equipment than Huawei.
And this case almost all operations are carried out by software software that
is in the cloud. And who makes that software? Well,
pretty much any company that.
[Inaudible], again.
It is something very similar to Apple versus windows. Apple is a closed system.
You buy an Apple computer and the most,
the screen and all the components are manufactured by Apple.
In the case of windows,
the most screen or hard drive can be from completely different manufacturers.
Well, the singles for Rakuten is five G for example,
radio equipment is being manufactured by another Japanese company called N E C
N. Wait a minute. I know what you're going to say.
So how are all these Japanese companies connected to being made in America?
Well, I think you can guess the answer,
many of the companies that are partnering with Rakuten are from the United
States. We're talking about well-known companies such as Cisco, red hat,
or even entail, but also some other, not so well companies,
companies like this one.
Altiostar raises 114 million funding round Rakuten joint says investor
running.
And work with components from different companies is a complicated task.
Anyone who's tried to set up a home cinema system will tell you that, well,
that's the hard part because then installing it on the ground is super simple.
The activation of a rockets in base station takes only eight and a half minutes
compared to up to three days for a traditional base station. And you'll say, so,
is this better or worse than Huawei? And the answer is,
we don't know at the moment, we can only say that in June of this year, 2020,
they're going to launch it. Okay.
[Inaudible].
And their rates are half of what the competition charges.
And it seems there are many more us companies willing to work with Rakuten.
As you can imagine for Trump's rhetoric,
this is enough to claim victory on the one hand as managed to avoid more
business with China on the other Rakuten,
as American enough to sell as mate an America. What's more, as you can imagine,
an attempt has already been made to claim the winner's trophy.
Okay? The race to 5g is a race.
America must win and it's a United States.
Our approach is private sector driven and private sector led the
government. Doesn't have to spend lots of money.
There's one thing we have to give to Trump at his tiny hands.
This is all good news. I mean, monopolies are bonded in any industry.
The fact that viable alternatives to far ways domain are emerging as good news
for everyone.
The bad news is that both the United States and Japan are opting for Rakuten
simply on a political basis.
It would be more great if politicians used more XL and less PowerPoint,
but this is visual politics. Here.
We talk about what's going on and not what we'd like to happen.
So now the question is over to you,
to what extent will the Rakuten formula be extended internationally?
Do you think China will continue to win the 5g race,
lead your answer in the comments below.
So we all really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe to in there for brand new videos every few days,
if you had the little alarm button,
you'll even get a recommendation for when they go up,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not my dulcet tunes. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
Learn more about politics and world affairs.
And here's some more of my lovely voice. Check out the reconsidered podcast,
where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or
Google play or your favorite podcast.